il est le joyau de la collection exposée
dans les grandes écuries du château de
versailles
il s'agit du carrosse du sacre de
charles 10,4 tonnes 5 mètres de haut
sept mètres de long
cette voiture est reconnu comme le
chef-d'oeuvre de la carrosserie
française pour l'ingéniosité de sa
mécanique la richesse de ses ors et des
ornements auquel concours tous les arts
décoratifs le carrosse dans la monarchie
française c'est le symbole du pouvoir du
pouvoir en marche et à versailles et
bien nous n'avons pas des véhicules pour
voyager nous n'avons donné que pour
montrer le roi donc il faut bien
comprendre que le carrosse c'est comme
un trône ambulants et trolls c'est à
dire aussi un objet d'art réalisées par
les meilleurs artistes et artisans de la
couronne fermé au public depuis 2007 la
galerie des carrosses vient de rouvrir
grâce au mécénat de la fondation
michelin la surface d'exposition a
doublé et s'étend à présent sur plus de
1000 mètres carrés
elle présente l'une des plus importantes
collections de carros d'europe
entièrement restauré différents films
faits à partir d'image de données de
captation 3d à l'intérieur des carrosses
permettent de comprendre l'apparition de
ces voitures est la technique utilisée
pour les fabriquer l'appareil
pédagogique est effectivement très
important pour les petits parce que
finalement c'est des collections un peu
insolite
donc il faut expliquer au public d'abord
et bien pourquoi ce sont des objets
d'histoire ici chaque cas roche d'une
page de l'histoire de france
et puis les faire aussi un peu rentrait
bien dans dans cette technique et pau
mobile du char funèbre de louis xviii
aux voitures de la présidence en passant
par les berlines du mariage de napoléon
1er
les carrosses de versailles ce sont des
monuments historiques et artistiques
à l'image des écuries royales bâti par
jules hardouin mansart entre 1679 et